the way you did you did an episode all
about the early days of grilling in
America so what did you learn a ton so I
mean the thing is you have to remember
barbecues used to be like this brick
structure that was immovable so if it
rained you couldn't bring it in couldn't
bring it under the shelter there was no
way to clean out charcoal and the Advent
of something like the Weber grill really
was a game changer and then after World
War II when you had the rise of Suburbia
having a grill was kind of a status
symbol yeah so it was really cool and of
course people forget that Henry Ford was
really the first pioneer of grilling and
he gave out barbecue grills with the
purchase of a new Model T Ford and the
thing that's so crazy is his wife's
cousin bought a Timber Mill because each
Model T took about a hundred board feet
of wood they had all this extra wood he
said listen we have these grills let's
make charcoal and he started this
charcoal Factory he hired Thomas Edison
to build a charcoal Factory and what was
his wife's cousin's last name Kingsford
and that's how Kingsford Charcoal was
corn and then eventually they moved on
and we now know the Weber grill and of
course if we're talking Weber well I
have it's the best yeah that's the best
it's that beautiful clam shell it's
aesthetically beautiful and naturally if
it's a company called Weber it was
founded by a man named George Stevens
who had 12 kids I used to say he was
like a welder with 12 kids he should
have welded a zipper shut but he can't
yeah right but a lot of cherry stem
tie-in exactly
nice nice call back you're welcome but
he had he had seen them building buoys
to Mark channels in the ocean he said
that's how I'm going to build a grill
and suddenly it was lightweight it was
portable you could spherical that's how
it it was it's always so Random if you
look at like uh Pringles that cam was
inspired by tennis balls the shape of
the Pringle the hyperbolic paraboloid
inspired by a saddle
um the box for Nerds candy of the year
in 1984. solidly so so good so good so
good it was made from the leftover bits
of everlasting Gobstoppers that were
left in the machine and those cool boxes
with the sliding doors those are
rejected packages from Winston and
Marlboro cigarettes what yes yes so
remember kids eat candy don't smoke
cigarettes when you're a kid oh I do in
the bubble gum I used to think I was too
I was still so inappropriate to have
kids walking around me like um
yes I came to a Jewish costume thing
dressed like Don Johnson from Miami Vice
with my no socks
very rough you were a hit yeah Don
Johnson wits very sexy and then I have
it Blow the little sugar out of my
things and you know people were like oh
it's awful with the kids with the fake
smoking it's terrible
I love you
[Music]
[Applause]